Did you play the game Mousetrap?
Or see a Rube Goldberg
machine at the science fair?
If our app were a Rube Goldberg machine,
then an instance of a class would
be one of its moving parts.
A class is a unit that we use to package
together related data and functionality.
A class is made up of properties and
methods, as you can see here
in this simple Movie class.
The properties are title,
director and release year.
And it only has one method,
an init method.
We'll talk about the specifics
of initialization shortly.
For now, just know that every class
needs an initialization method.
Notice that the properties are generally
defined at the top of the class,
followed by the methods.
Here's another class you've seen before,
the Moviearchive class.
This one has a property that's
an array of movie objects.
And in addition to its init method, it
has a familiar method, filter by year.
You can see that, apart from
the placement of the code between these
curly braces, defining properties in a
class is no different from defining any
other variable or constant.
And defining methods in a class is
no different from defining global
functions.